who does Dr Dre listen to now who is Dr
Dre embracing in these times I get this
question all the time Kevin it's like um
but don't [__] make it seem like my
question wasn't [__] no not such a great
[__] question it is a good question I
just hit you with a Susie stop that okay
no I didn't mean it like that who do you
like
um I'm listening to different genres of
music all the time you know
um I might you know
this week I might be listening to 70s so
next week I might be listening to the
rock or the Beatles or some [__] like
that I'm all over the place
I might be listening to some [__]
poker or something when I leave here I
don't know I get inspiration from all
types of genres of music you know I I
don't know I don't have a I don't
necessarily have a favorite I have a
favorite of the week let me put it like
okay okay I like that when when we're
talking about
uh the artists I'm beyond impressed with
the work and body of work of Kendrick
Lamar yeah for you to be somebody that
was
um influential in the course of part of
his career early on to see him now grow
into the artist that he is I can't take
credit I didn't say take credit I'm
saying to T to see him grow yeah I
didn't I didn't say responsible
and so what he is today Kendrick Lamar
is a real [__] artist yeah like
yeah true definition of the word
absolutely you know the only thing I can
take credit for is opening the door for
him because he's done everything himself
him and Day free what's that
relationship like with you we have a
fantastic relationship yeah I like I
like
I like the fact that you're well the way
that I look at things I'm I'm extremely
observant and watching Kendrick seeing
Kendrick from
early on young rapper the BET cyphers to
eventually get into the album damn to
them growing and developing into an
artist that really had to be moved
um to go and actually put his craft uh
in in a space for people to hear it to
then get to where he is like to date
he's not he's amazing man let me
Kendrick is one of those those artists
that we call Forever artists okay Define
that for me he could he could disappear
for [__] five years or something like
that and come back and [__] our heads up
yeah you know some artists feel like I
have to do something all the time so I
won't be forgotten you know that's not
him he can disappear and come back with
something that's shocking that's a
amazing and everybody's going to tune in
and listen do you have another example
of a forever artist
um
Snoop Eminem forever if we're talking
about just artists that I've worked with
in general just I like I like that yeah
you know I mean that's a a really tough
question to answer you know because all
of a sudden we were talking about
Michael and Prince and all that [__] you
know what I mean of course those are for
other artists but let's talk about like
the climate now rap now right uh a lot
of older rappers
um some of them that come from well well
you know we're not gonna put an age
number on it right we're not gonna but
let's just say a lot of rappers from
from back then from back in the day yeah
a lot of rappers were back in the day
like how how far rappers that can relate
to either
punch a curse word at the end and doing
it or noise rappers have been quoted
um you know just speaking on the state
of hip-hop today right or the Artistry
or the enthusiasm or you know if it is
are you saying rappers today speaking on
the state of hip-hop today
I remember speaking on the state of it
right okay some have been quoted and not
supporting or against or not embracing
younger rappers just felt like we don't
get enough love [__] that from the old
heads what is your take [__] that let me
tell you something hip-hop is what it is
anybody that's talking about the state
of hip-hop right now when talking about
it from a negative Place sounds like
somebody's [__] grandfather okay you
know what I'm saying I love that this is
just what it is hip Papa's evolving if
you don't like it don't listen to it you
know what I'm saying I'm keeping it all
the way 100 with you some of this [__]
most of the [__] I don't like
I don't listen to a lot of that [__] but
I'm not hating on it yeah I'm never
gonna hate on it it's evolving
in these kids are using what they have
at their fingertips right I mean back in
the day I used to have to go out and buy
[__] keyboards and buy sounds
from pawn shops and [__] like that to
get my sounds out they have everything
at their fingertips right now but you
can't be mad at that
[Music]
laughs